okay i've watched this
[Music]
let's meal prep
[Music]
i'm a busy lady even though i'm a
cookbook author and a dietitian i would
be lying if i said that i cooked every
meal from scratch i don't and you will
find tons of pinterest inspiration for
meal prep meals where you make one meal
and you like divvy it up into different
little containers so you can eat it
throughout the week but i don't do that
i just
don't like it my family gets really
bored of eating the same thing so i
can't just serve the exact same meal
that i prepped for lunch and dinner
several days in the week i've also just
found on my own intuitive eating journey
that eating chicken and broccoli and
rice five days a week sometimes just
doesn't satisfy so how i like to meal
prep is i make a few batches of what i
call building blocks so i've got my veg
i've got my carbs i've got my protein
and then when five o'clock rolls around
and everyone's losing their because
they're hangry
i just kind of figure out how to
assemble it into a simple meal i've got
two young kids so we don't do a lot of
fancy things anymore because my kids
like to have things pretty simple plain
and let's be real not touching no touchy
so i end up having to add like sauces or
certain spices afterwards for my husband
and myself anyway it's not gourmet but
it's nourishment and it takes the stress
away from cooking and eating for me and
my family and that is really important
for me at this stage of life so let me
show you how i do it all right first
things first let's start with the veg we
eat a lot of vegetables in my house in
various forms roasted steamed eaten raw
as a salad and my kids also really love
vegetables i know i'm super blessed with
that um but i like to have those things
on hand for quick easy snacks or for
meal building blocks so let's get
shopping
[Music]
[Music]
so my son e only likes the red bell
peppers because he says they're iron man
bell peppers which is a great little tip
if your kids have a specific character
that they are obsessed with like the
hulk we call like hulk broccoli and
things like that it's a really great way
to get them involved but i found these
cool straight bell peppers and i'm gonna
call them rainbow bell peppers and i
think he's gonna be into that
[Music]
it seems like a lot of chopping and a
lot of work but it takes me about like
30 minutes on a weekend during nap time
and it saves me endless amount of work
throughout the week
[Music]
feels appropriate
now let's work on a good solid base carb
that my family can enjoy easily
throughout the week usually that's rice
because my kids are obsessed with rice
and also tons of fruit we go through an
excessive amount of fruit in my house so
let's get to it
[Music]
so obviously you can cook your rice with
just plain water and often we do but i
love to use a broth especially like a
bone broth because it does add some
extra protein and a lot more flavor
[Music]
let's wash them through
[Music]
by the way to the fruit lady who says i
don't feed my family enough fruit you
should see my grocery bill it's intense
[Music]
[Music]
i usually like to let them just dry on a
kitchen towel just for like 30 minutes
or so before i package them up just to
help them last a little bit longer in
the fridge
runaways
naughty little things
so i usually cook this on a bit of like
the thicker drier side and then when
it's time to reheat it i can just add as
much milk or extra water or whatever it
is that i want to add to it in the
microwave when i'm repeating all right
it's time to work on our proteins and i
usually just do one or two simple
versatile proteins that we can throw
into different things throughout the
week this week it's going to be some
hard-boiled eggs and some chicken
breasts okay so i normally make my
hard-boiled eggs just in a pot but it
seems like everyone on instagram and
tiktok and youtube is swearing
that the instapot makes them perfect
every time so
i found this video on youtube and i'm
gonna try for the first time here folks
so
wish me luck
[Music]
well five minutes
let's hope that works
so i just threw a quick little balsamic
marinade on this
um just to add a little bit of extra
flavor and we also know that adding
marinades that are vinegar-based can
actually cut back on the carcinogens
caused by grilling so it's a really
great hack if you are doing a lot of
barbecuing in the summer
[Music]
the lady on youtube said this was like
foolproof
easy
fast i have been waiting
for a long time and i'm not sure what's
going on in there so i am getting a
little bit anxious about my inks that
is not a perfect hard-boiled egg
that is
really gross
it's just that this guy got a little bit
excited
he just got excited jumped the gun
it's okay we'd still eat that
look at that right now so when we have
those easy building blocks in place
there are so many different options for
building hunger crushing combos so here
are some super simple ideas i've got
some basic greek yogurt in the fridge
that i top with some berries and serve
my hard-boiled eggs
over here we've got our oatmeal i topped
with some nut butter and our berries
that we washed i made a quick little
sandwich we got bread we've got all of
our roasted vegetables our sliced
veggies and lettuce plus our chicken
breast as well and i threw some
store-bought hummus on there for good
measure over here we've got some of our
cooked rice with lots of veggies as a
little stir fry i topped it off with our
chicken breast and some nuts that i had
in the pantry and whatever sauce that
you have on hand that you and your
family likes over here i've got some
easy ramen noodles i just threw in some
hot water added a store-bought ramen
broth threw my egg on top and any of my
vegetables in there as well and then a
quick little salad with our chopped
lettuce i've got our chicken on here
i've got lots of the vegetables that are
chopped up and roasted i topped it off
with some dressing some cheese from the
fridge and some pistachios from the
pantry so the possibilities are really
endless with a meal prep like this you
choose a couple veg you choose a couple
carbs you choose a couple sources of
protein and you can mix and match with
whatever easy staples that you already
have in your pantry or fridge that are
pre-made and ready to go this saves me
so much time and it also saves me so
much money because i'm not scrambling at
5 p.m trying to get dinner on the table
and end up inevitably just ordering
something in so everyone i hope that was
helpful for you if you like this video
please be sure to give it the thumbs up
leave me a comment below on what kind of
videos like this you'd like to see me do
next subscribe to the channel and i'll
see you next time on abby's kitchen bye
[Music]